If scientists could create a pill that let you live...
...twice as long while remaining free of infirmities, would you take it?
If one considers only the personal benefits that longer life would bring,...
...the answer might seem like a no-brainer:
People could spend more quality time with loved ones;
watch future generations grow up;
learn new languages;
master new musical instruments;
try different careers or travel the world.
But what about society as a whole?
Would it be better off if lifespans were doubled?
A doubled lifespan gives us a chance to recover from our mistakes,...
...leads us towards longer - term thinking...
...and reduces health care costs by delaying the onset of expensive diseases of aging.
It also raises productivity by adding to our prime years.
Conversely, doubling lifespans won't solve our current social problems.
War, poverty, etc. may not be helped by having people live longer.
We must ask, "What will we get as a society?"
Others point out that a doubling of the human lifespan will affect society at every level.
Notions about marriage, family and work, will change in fundamental ways they say,...
...as will attitudes toward the young and the old...
While opinions differ wildly about what the ramifications for society will be...
...if the human lifespan is extended,...
...most ethicists agree that the issue should be discussed now,...
...since it might be impossible to stop or control the technology...
...once it's developed.